-Our next guest is CNN's
chief political correspondent
and co-anchor
of "State of the Union,"
which airs Sunday mornings
at 9:00 on CNN.
Please welcome back to the show,
Dana Bash.
♪♪
-Hi!
[ Applause ]
Nice to see you in person.
-I know.
Thank you for making the trip.
-My pleasure.
Thank you.
♪♪
-This is very nice.
Last time I saw you
was on a Zoom screen.
-I know.
I know.
We're inching,
inching back to normalcy.
-Well, then, a very
interesting thing, though.
The tables were turned.
You came here,
and I think a first for us --
you were just
on a CNN Zoom screen.
-I was.
-You did a live hit
from our dressing room.
-I did.
-Because, you know,
we tape this early in the day.
Joe Biden has just spoken
while we are talking here.
What was your reaction,
not just to the speed in which
the Taliban has taken back
the country
but Joe Biden's remarks today?
-They were very focused on what
you mentioned in your open,
which is that Americans are done
with this 20-year war, right?
And so it was
for domestic consumption.
It was making the case that,
as bad and as hard as this is,
that if it didn't happen now,
it could've happened
five years ago,
if the U.S. pulled out then,
or 15 years ago
if the U.S. stays longer.
But it doesn't change the fact
that we still don't know why
the execution
seemed so bungled, right?
-Yeah.
-I mean, the fact that we have
these images, but the images
tell the story of people
who were asking to get out
and knew this deadline
was coming
and didn't get approval
or didn't get the green light
and just didn't get taken out
before this happened.
-Yeah.
Because there's been
a lot of reporting
of people in Afghanistan
knew this day were coming.
You know,
this special immigrant visa.
18,000 people, at least,
who are backlogged.
So they knew it was coming.
And I think another thing
to keep in mind is,
I don't think a lot Americans,
day-to-day,
think about Afghanistan.
-Definitely not.
-But we now have these images
that are sort of indelible
as to what we're seeing.
And yet we also have
these bad-faith arguments
by those on the right
who are forgetting that the plan
that is being carried out
right now
was Donald Trump's plan.
-He put it in place.
He set the deadline.
Well, let me back up.
He made the agreement inside
Afghanistan for the pullout.
He pulled
most of the troops out,
save for 2,500,
and then set the deadline.
So the only question for
Joe Biden when he took office
is whether or not he would
stand by that or change things.
And when he was Vice President,
he, I guess now famously,
was a very minority voice
within the Obama administration
telling then President Obama,
"We should get out now."
And President Obama
ultimately decided to stay.
But it is just a reminder
that now President Biden
has wanted to get out of
Afghanistan for quite some time.
And that's what he basically
said in his speech,
that we need to end this,
and we need to focus,
as Americans, on threats
that are much more grave,
much more pressing,
like China and like Russia.
-You reported
from inside Afghanistan
at a time when there
maybe was some optimism.
-It was so different, Seth.
I was with
then Vice President Cheney.
First we made a surprise trip
to Iraq,
which is
a whole different story.
But then,
we went to Afghanistan,
and the reason he was there,
it was because
it was the opening
of the General Assembly.
And so it was
totally bizarre to go in.
I was part
of a very small press pool.
But he went in,
and then we followed
to a very small,
smoke-filled room.
But there were elected members
of the Parliament
inside Afghanistan.
And there were women there,
there were members
of the Taliban who were elected,
sitting side by side.
And I remember thinking,
"Wow! This is amazing,"
and wondering
if it was fleeting.
And the answer is yes,
because it is, as you said,
hubris for America,
time and time again,
to try to impose ideals
and a philosophy on a place
that just
isn't interested in it,
and that was proved
by the fact that 300,000 --
or however many Afghan troops
were trained, and they,
for whatever reason,
just didn't have the will --
obviously,
there was fear in there,
but they didn't
have the will to fight.
-You --
We talked about it.
You reported in Afghanistan.
We're very lucky right now
to have people reporting
on the ground,
which talking about fear,
you know, I will say
the safety of my desk is about
as much as I would risk.
-You and me both.
-And your colleague,
Clarissa Ward,
who's been doing reporting
from inside the country, and,
you know, there is sort of
an 8-second clip
that's going around right now,
as well as a meme
that she's addressed.
And, again,
these are bad-faith actors,
both elected officials
and in the media,
who are trying to frame
what she said.
How upsetting is it to you
that -- especially when they're
attacking the people
that are doing the sort of,
you know, the boot leather,
actually being there
in real time.
-I don't even have words to
describe how upsetting it is,
because you're exactly right.
She is there.
She is on the ground.
She is reporting, real time,
what is happening
in the most dangerous
of circumstances
for anybody of any gender,
and here she is
as a woman doing it
and confronting members of the
Taliban, who said to her --
she was covered, but she needed
to be covered more
because you could
still see her face.
She needed to be covered more
because you could
still see her fingers --
she needed to be wearing gloves.
And she's doing her reporting
for everybody in the world,
particularly Americans,
with these kinds of dangers
and these kinds of realities.
And for all the people
who criticize her,
I'd like them to go spend
5 seconds in her shoes,
never mind five minutes,
or five days and -- or months,
which is what
she has done, combined.
She's such a badass, Seth.
I mean, I can't say --
And by the way, not for nothing,
she has two babies at home.
She's a mom.
-It is -- it is truly --
truly impressive.
Although I have two kids
at home,
and there are times where
that's when I want
to go to Afghanistan.
[ Laughter ]
-I hear you.
-Yeah. You know --
You know the feeling,
where you're like,
"I'm gonna go somewhere
a little bit more low-key."
-Um --
[ Laughter ]
So, I want to talk to you --
the last time we spoke,
you were with
a couple of your colleagues.
And now a lot has changed
even since then.
You're co-hosting
"State of the Union."
-Mm-hmm.
-Your career began
when the news -- technology
was certainly different.
-Yeah.
-What were your early days
in journalism?
-Well, I started at CNN
right out of college.
In fact, I was still in school.
It was my second semester
of my senior year.
I was living in Washington,
and I started freelancing.
And my first job job
I got right on my 22nd birthday.
And -- Which is in the summer,
right after I graduated.
And it was
to work in a tape library.
So that means
that there was videotape.
-Yeah.
-And there was a library for --
to house that videotape,
and none of that exists anymore.
I mean, we don't do videotape,
right?
It's all --
And so when I tell people that,
they're like, "What is that?"
I said, "You know the thing
that you see in the movies,
where they put the --
the, you know --
Go back and watch
'Broadcast News,'" which also
the kids don't know what it is.
-[ Laughing ] Exactly.
-But that's what --
But that's basically
what it was.
That was the technology
back then.
-I mean, I --
I worked as an intern
for Comedy Central
in the mid '90s,
and my job was literally
running videotapes --
getting in taxis
and running videotapes
to other parts of the city.
It was --
And it's crazy to think back.
-That's amazing. Yeah.
-'Cause, again,
you just can't -- you --
None of us can conceive
of the fact that our 20s
will be ancient history.
You know?
-Ancient, ancient history.
I mean, to think
that we didn't have --
I mean, we barely had e-mail.
-Yeah.
-We barely had the Internet.
We barely had any of that.
God, I feel like
I'm 100 years old.
I should stop talking.
-Yeah, we should stop.
Let's talk about someone
that young people like -- AOC.
-Yeah.
-You did -- you did a --
basically an hour special
with her.
And you've obviously interviewed
and spent time
with many politicians.
I don't think I'm alone
in making the comment
that there's
something unique about her.
What did you find
in your time with her?
-There is. And, you know,
you had a cameo...
-I was very happy
to make a cameo. Thank you.
-...in that hour,
because, when I was doing my --
my research, I watched
the interview that she did.
She's sitting right here
with you,
and there was
such a classic moment.
I was trying to figure out
how to get at the fact
that one of the reasons
she is so polarizing,
and in particular,
people on the right
are so fixated on her,
is because she's so beautiful,
and she's so young,
and they don't really know
what to do with her,
and you just nailed it.
You just went at it in
a very, very clever way.
So instead of me figuring out
how to ask the question,
I just put it right on you.
-Thank you.
Look, any time I can find my way
into stuff on other networks,
'cause I'm trying to, like,
spread it out, you know?
Yeah.
-Yeah. Well, yeah.
It was very welcomed.
-But, there is something
about her that I feel like
you pointed out,
which is that she's also not
ashamed of those things.
I feel like there -- you know,
there's this long history
of women politicians having to,
you know, like,
bend themselves towards
what we perceive
as strengths
of male politicians.
And she sort of unapologetically
doesn't do that.
-My favorite segment in this
hour that we did was about that,
which is that she said,
"There is power in femininity,
and that's why I own it."
I mean, she did a tutorial
for "Vogue" magazine
where she did
her whole beauty routine,
including her famous red lips.
And not a lot of women
politicians would ever do that,
and the reason is because,
for the most part,
women conform to the idea
of male power,
and that's the argument
that she was making.
And it's not even something
that ever occurred to me.
And I think it's generational,
and -- and it's very unique
to her, which is
part of the conversation
that I thought
was so interesting.
-Well, it's always interesting
talking to you.
I really do appreciate you
making the trip in person.
-I'm so glad to be here.
-And hopefully
we'll see you soon.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-You guys, "State of the Union"
airs Sundays at 9:00 a.m.
and noon on CNN.